welcome to their famous Friday I believe
that whatever goal you have whatever
challenge is in front of you the easiest
way the fastest way to go and accomplish
it is to model success find someone
who's already doing what you want to do
learn what made them successful and
apply it to your business so today we're
going to learn from Carl Benz whose
company eventually became mercedes-benz
and his lesson is follow your dreams
when Carl Benz was 2 years old his
father who was a locomotive driver was
killed he grew up in absolute poverty
but his mother made sure that it
continued to get his education and
further his studies
initially he went into locksmithing that
was the box that he was put into but he
wanted to follow his dreams follow in
his father's footsteps and go into
locomotive engineering he also had a
passion for riding his bicycle and
dreamed of a day where there'd be a
horseless carriage where people could be
able to get around on a vehicle that
didn't require a horse after he finished
his studies he spent seven years
bouncing around trying to find himself
he took jobs in mechanical engineering
as a draftsman as an iron worker in the
construction company as a designer but
he couldn't find a position that he
really loved and instead of doing the
safe thing and sticking with one job for
the rest of his life he decided the best
thing for him would be continue to
explore until he found something he
loved so at age 26 after spending the
past seven years failing and bouncing
from job to job to job he decided to
launch his own company with a partner
unfortunately his partner wasn't really
reputable and after a year all of the
company's assets and tools and equipment
were impounded so he set up another
company with a photographer and a cheese
merchant merging the businesses together
so they can get money from the bank but
he got his shares diluted to owning just
5% of the company and had a really lowly
role in the business the worst part was
the other founders didn't consider his
ideas when they were designing new
products so after a year he left so now
he has seven years of failing in the job
market and two failed startup businesses
under his bed
what would you do if you were in this
situation most people will be filled
with despair they feel like I've tried
everything I've tried every job I've
tried every business and it's not
working out what am I supposed to do so
he tapped back into his love of bicycles
and his dream of building the horseless
carriage he visited a local bicycle shop
got to know the two partners who founded
it and with them started a new business
his goal was to build the first
horseless carriage which would become
known as the automobile so after working
away for two years he finally had his
first prototype he was so excited
finally the first automobile and he set
up a live demonstration to show
everybody what his new invention could
do so in 1885 he set up the public
demonstration and unfortunately the
automobile was too difficult to control
and in front of everybody smashed into a
wall so here he is after two years of
research into developing and making this
prototype after two years before four
failed businesses after seven years
before failed jobs
everything's leading up to this moment
this day here it is is finally arrived
and it's a huge public failure for him
so what would you do that would you give
up and go do the same thing again and
get a job
it was Karl's dream so he had to keep
going it took him another two years of
developing and tinkering and modifying
before he had a product that was ready
for another big public demonstration in
1887 he had his new prototype ready for
demonstration at the Paris Expo it was a
success and in the summer of 1888 he
started taking orders and he had now the
first commercially available automobile
in history his dream of building a
horseless carriage had been realized and
he was on his way to building a
worldwide brand name this is a really
important lesson for you guys because if
you have a dream there's going to be
people who tell you not to do it you're
going to try a lot of things and you're
going to fail it might take years of
failing and failing and failing and
failing with no light anywhere at the
end of the tunnel
what keeps you motivated to keep going
you're going to want to quit and throw
in the towel multiple times the only
thing that keeps you excited is that
dream
it's at times in the rational belief
that you can make this dream a reality
and if you listen to your dream and
continue to take steps every day to move
towards it eventually you'll accomplish
it I maybe build a world recognizable
brand in the process to belief if you
guys like this video you want to see
more subscribe to the channel and let me
know what you think about this video by
leaving a comment below thank you so
much for watching and I'll see you soon
even your music isn't totally not secret
I look forward to them every they have
changed my life thank you
you